do you think culture Society can change
the nature of man no
so no matter you don't think this idea
that uh for example America has been
founded on that all men are created the
equal
that that idea can't permeate the
culture and in thereby change how we see
each other how we
think of the basic worth of a human
being and thereby change our nature it
doesn't change that's epigenetic I don't
I don't think that that changes the
nature of man I think for example if I
say someone which I agree with that if
someone is innocent so proven guilty
they're not literally innocent they're
regarded in a legal context as innocent
but that person is or is not a murderer
or a thief or so on and so forth so we
can
legally and ethically regard everyone is
equal but as Thomas sull pointed out a
human being isn't even equal to himself
over the course of a day twins who are
genetic clones are not equal to one
another so it is a important thing
legally and it's a good yardstick but
it's not literally true but don't you
think that law becomes ethics so we
um
we that like idea of Justice starts to
like we start to internalize it that we
just
the way we behave the way we think about
the world no I I I think it's a complete
red herring because no one is no you're
a red herring okay see what I did there
um
because
someone is people are still going to
always prefer their family to strangers
or they're in group to our group so in
terms of you're going to have equality
that means it's going to not matter to
you whether someone is your mom or
someone is you know someone down the
street and I don't see how that will
ever become the case